So something that you might have heard of
when it comes to the NHS are the 6 C's.
Now, the NHS aims to embody and recruit staff
according to these 6 C's.
Medical schools also often use these criteria
to recruit new medical students.
Therefore, many of the questions that you might be asked
are designed to test these core values.
A top tip is to try and identify which of the values
they are referring to in the station
that you can be more targeted with your answer.
So let's look at these sixes in a bit more detail.
The sixes are care,
compassion, communication,
competence, commitment and courage.
It's important that you are able to
refer back to some of the work experience
or the volunteering that you've done
to demonstrate that you align with those values.